[Musique]
chaque été on a l'habitude d'entendre ce
fameux bruit assourdissant
mais cette fois c'est un moustique
silencieux qui semble nous envahir avec
ses rayures blanches le moustique tigre
originaire d'Asie tropical s'est répandu
un peu partout dans l'Hexagone et a
rendu fou les Français cet été on sent
vraiment que on se fait manger
complètement beaucoup plus que les
années d'avant à Paris une opération de
démoustication a même
eu proliférer grâce à la hausse des
températures peut nous transmettre de
graves maladies notamment
alors comment faire pour en venir à bout
on en parle ce soir dans TPMP
et oui les moustiques les moustiques
tigres alors déjà qu'est-ce qu'un
moustique tigre parce qu'on avant on
peut les moustiques normal romain merci
Romain d'ailleurs d'être là vous
embrasserez la sœur
j'avais attendu déjà tout à l'heure
pourquoi on appelle les mousses pourquoi
les moustiques et maintenant on dit les
moustiques tigres parce que jusqu'en
2004-205 en fait on avait des espèces
communes en France des moustiques des
marais et qui sortaient beaucoup pendant
les vacances
et maintenant c'est quoi maintenant ils
viennent tout et en fait le tigre il a
été introduit en France en 2004 avec des
importations asiatiques
avec Frosties
et donc il a été introduit en France en
et donc
en fait avant il était pas présent hein
par des importations de produits chinois
notamment et en fait notamment vous
voyez tous les Lucky bambou ces petits
bambous qu'on peut acheter dans les dans
les jardineries et en fait on aurait des
larves qui seraient arrivés dans dans
les liquides qui ont voyagé avec celloki
bambou et donc on les a introduit quand
même et comme toutes les espèces
invasives et notamment celles qui
boivent du sang parce que c'est
récurrent moi je viens pour parler des
trucs qui pompent du temps et du coup on
les a introduits c'est 2004 et
aujourd'hui 72 départements concernés
en fait on le reconnaît parce qu'il a
une barre blanche sur le thorax et puis
les pâtes années de blanc en fait et
c'est comme ça qu'on le reconnaît et
particularité parce qu'il est petit j'ai
jamais vu un moustique moi comme ça
alors c'est le père des moustiques mais
les autres mais lui il est zébré comme
ça et lui alors il est très dangereux
celui-là ouais alors effectivement
l'autre particularité tu dois t'en
apercevoir c'est qui pique la journée si
vous commencez à être piqué la journée
c'est que c'est du tigre ça c'est il va
commencer vers 17h ouais je sais il se
lève tard
il était à l'arc avec moi je l'ai revu à
17h il avait la gueule en biais il m'a
piqué comme un con je l'ai en étant sans
hier soir en train de boire des verres
et là tu me piques non mais tu es con
comme une pendule non mais c'est vrai et
donc il se lève à 17h la gueule en biais
et il pique et là il y a les gars on y
va on va piquer là il y en a qui font
doliprane lui donc
ouais alors il va piquer la journée les
gens qui font du jardin par exemple
quand un jardin et le reste de la
journée il reste sous les sous les sous
les feuilles de plantes en fait ah ouais
d'accord et donc on les détecte pas
alors tu dis qu'il est dangereux ouais
il a amené un nouveau danger vous devez
en entendre parler aujourd'hui c'est la
dingue donc pas là aujourd'hui
viens demain
et en fait c'est des nouvelles maladies
qu'on appelait des maladies tropicales
et aujourd'hui c'est des maladies qui
sont en France puisque cette année 2023
on a déjà un peu plus de 600 cas de
dingues en France donc voilà et les
quatre dingue au niveau mondial c'est
400 millions de cas par an OK et donc
100 millions de cas sévères 100 millions
de dingue ouais à mon avis il doit être
alors c'est une maladie infectieuse donc
fièvre fièvre enfin la maladie ouais ça
peut être dangereux c'est chez un
certain nombre de gens je te dis sur 400
millions de cas de dingues au niveau
mondial c'est 100 millions de cas qui
nécessitent une hospitalisation et qui
peuvent conduire à la mort quoi
dans la nuit qui suit de la fièvre il
faut aller à l'hôpital alors c'est pas
dans la nuit qui suit ça mais entre 6 et
10 jours 4 incubation donc finalement il
y a 10 jours tu étais où tu développes
un syndrome grippal quelle maladie ne
commence pas par un syndrome rippal ça
c'est pas évident donc et puis la
plupart du temps en fait ça cesse tu ne
présentes plus de symptômes sauf que
dans dans un cas sur 4 un cas sur 5 et
bien ça nécessite une hospitalisation ça
fait une dingue sévère et la grosse
problématique c'est que si tu l'as tu as
déjà chopé une fois la dingue et que tu
la rechoppes une deuxième fois la
deuxième fois c'est probablement un
cassé vert non ah ouais donc en fait
c'était 61 un peu plus de 75 en 2022 642
2023 bon
et le moustique
tu peux y aller
[Applaudissements]
non mais comment donc pour les femmes
enceintes aussi le moustique le
moustique tigre il pique de 17h à quelle
heure lui bah au début de nuit en fait
début de nuit il peut quand même piquer
la nuit mais il a la particularité
d'être reconnu par ce qui pique la
journée alors qu'avant ça nous arrivait
pas bien sûr avant ça arrivait pas alors
donc ça c'est la carte voilà voilà la
carte de répartition du moustique tigre
en France
alors il est pas du tout dans le Nord
bah il est en train de progresser parce
qu'en fait
je crois je pense donc
il est pas du tout dans le Nord
c'est parce que effectivement on a moins
de surveillance non ça département là
c'est départements très ruraux il fait
pas le même bruit que les autres c'est
vrai il fait quoi comme
effet
ouais en fait on l'entend beaucoup moins
il pique beaucoup moins longtemps et
donc en fait on s'aperçoit sa présence
malheureusement quand il a il pique tout
le monde de la même façon parce que j'ai
l'impression souvent quand je suis avec
des personnes plus âgée que moi c'est
moi qui me fait piquer et elle non
est-ce que tout simplement
tout simplement tout simplement tu as eu
des Macchabées forcément il épique pas
le driver c'est le moustique c'est
surtout le rhésus sanguin et puis après
la température à la surface de la peau
dégagement de CO2 donc en fait comme la
punaise de lit on l'avait dit on l'a dit
la semaine dernière il passe en
corrélation je crois et en fait c'est le
même processus quand tu regardes les
bestioles c'est exactement les mêmes
processus c'est un placard si tu luttes
pas contre ça 72 départements sur un
temps après alors ce fait le plus piquer
vous avez parlé de Rhésus qui se fait
plus sucer quel groupe ça peut pas
répondre ça je peux pas répondre à ça
piquer j'ai un élément de réponse
il y a différents Rhésus sanguins
notamment les hauts négatifs et aux
positifs où il y a une vraie grosse
différence de piqûre et c'est la raison
pour laquelle bah en fait la nuit la
nuit il y a des gens qui sont piqués et
d'autres pas du tout et les personnes
âgées ça n'a rien à voir non
s'il te plaît
mais à chaque fois les je suis désolé
les personnes je sais pas mais qui tu
traînes mais calme-toi
calme-toi romain romain juste c'est vrai
que c'est un enfer c'est un enfer
franchement je vais passer mes journées
à à combattre le moustique cet été voilà
le combat il est
morte
ah ouais mais en fait j'ai installé un
truc chez moi et te dire tu vas me dire
si c'est bien c'est des bornes comme ça
j'avais vu un reportage sur France 5 à
une nuit comme ça bam j'ai la gueule en
biais aussi comme si je regarde il y a
il montrait un château avec des trucs tu
sais il disait il y avait plein de
moustiques on a trouvé un truc c'est un
processus un procédé il te met des
bornes comme ça qui reproduisent l'odeur
humaine qui dégage du CO2 qui dégage du
CO2 et les moustiques viennent là et là
bim ils sont inspirés par un petit
aspirateur
[Applaudissements]
vas-y vous avez cru que c'était moi vous
avez cru que c'était moi et voilà j'ai
fait ça tous l'été en fait ouais là on
l'a on arrive sur les solutions il y a
des solutions qui sont accessibles pour
les particuliers dans les dans les dans
les magasins spécialisés agricole et
autres où vous pouvez accéder à des à
des pièges qui ont une efficacité quand
même
qui est prouvé mais qui va rester limité
par rapport aux solutions que tu peux
faire installer chez toi avec des pros
ça marche bien ça ouais ça marche bien
ouais ouais c'est des sols machine ouais
alors c'est c'est quelques milliers
d'euros mais c'est
faut vraiment alors ces quelques c'est
quelques millions d'euros c'est quelques
billets d'euros
ouais alors effectivement il faut
quadriller c'est de la protection
périmétrique ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que les moustiques qui vous piquent chez
vous c'est globalement vous qui les
produisez ça fait 150 200 m dans sa vie
non mais comment les produits là tu
laisses de l'eau dehors dans les pots de
fleurs avant les moustiques ils vivaient
dans les marais et aujourd'hui comme par
exemple je sais qu'il y en a ici qui ont
des piscines
c'est vrai non mais je le dis voilà je
dénoncer personne
on a l'impression parce que j'étais chez
un pote à 18h tu peux pas aller dans la
piscine ce qu'il y a tous les moustiques
qui arrivent ouais mais la piscine
attention la piscine c'est pas un lieu
de reproduction des moustiques il y a du
chlore et donc les larves se développent
pas donc il faut chercher ailleurs et
donc la journée ils sont dans les arbres
sous les plantes d'accord et puis bah et
puis quand il sort le soir
les arrosoirs les jouets des gosses qui
restent pendant les vacances de la
récupération d'eau de pluie non protégés
avec un filet toutes ces choses là la
problématique c'est qu'on se vient
schizophrène avec le moustique
c'est que en fait il y a pas besoin
d'avoir des étangs autour de chez soi
c'est les petites réserves d'eau qu'on a
chez soi qui produisent les moustiques
ouais mais 20 ml 30 ml de flotte ça
suffit parce que moi j'avais des
personnes âgées à la maison
revenons-en malheureusement voilà les
mêmes que lui non mais et c'est vrai
qu'on aille très peur qu'elle se fasse
piquer parce que c'est vrai que à un
moment on avait peur de la de la dengue
donc aujourd'hui ce qui est clair c'est
qu'il y a un vrai risque de santé
publique avec la dengue on voit bien que
on est c'est exponentiel le nombre de
cas en France on a quand même
l'impression que les autorités
réagissent pas trop on est juste à
quelques semaines des autres les
punaises les moustiques quelques
semaines des JO et potentiellement il y
a le gouvernement avec commandé un
rapport à l'autorité donc notamment l'un
de cesse pour évaluer ce risque
sanitaire posé posé par le moustique
tigre et on attend toujours le rapport
Alan sauf que là on est à quelques
semaines des JO et on connaît toujours
pas le risque auquel on exploite
toujours pas
on l'a toujours pas eu la teste juste
est-ce qu'on peut se faire piquer en
hiver alors en hiver tu as pu d'activité
parce que c'est plutôt les donc les
femelles fécondées qui vont passer la
mauvaise saison ou des larves dans des
réserves d'eau et si tu veux tapis
d'activité c'est comme les insectes sont
très dépendants de la température
extérieure l'hiver alors c'est pourquoi
on a l'impression qu'il y avait beaucoup
plus cet été en France même dans le sud
et parce que il y en avait beaucoup plus
d'accord tout simplement
parce qu'en fait j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a plus de tout mais ouais parce que
les gens luttent c'est un nouvel insecte
qu'on connaît pas
au début tu es content de le voir il va
vite
alors ce qui marche bien c'est les
bornes répulsives voire même se mettre
du répulsif sur soi ça c'est relou ça je
déteste donc attention le moustique
ouais
les bornes quand on vit dans un dans un
400 m², ça va pas beaucoup marcher ça va
je parle pas pour moi encore une fois
non mais attends et dis-moi juste les
les trucs ça marche est-ce que ça marche
la Clim alors si vous baissez la
température il y a moins d'activité
est-ce que les moustiques n'aiment pas
c'est les flux d'air les ventilateurs en
fait il y a beaucoup de gens qui se
protègent en mettant du ventilateur la
nuit ventilateur et les moustiques qui
arrivent pas voler en fait donc c'est
vrai que bah le contexte il est là en
France on a l'impression qu'on patauge
un peu dans la problématique donc nous
on essaie de faire avancer les
professionnels sur ce sujet là on a
développé des applications donc une qui
s'appelle zap qui va permettre aux
particuliers de se déclarer et d'essayer
de mettre on est en train de de lui
proposer des petits gestes de tous les
jours pour qui pour éviter le style pour
pour qu'il fasse des efforts et qui
permettent
d'infléchir la population de moustiques
n'empêche que si le voisin il fait rien
bah les moustiques qui sautent là et
quoi je veux dire après c'est le serpent
qui se mord lait on a on a pas de vision
globale sur ce sujet là on a
malheureusement que des outils pour se
protéger là et bien il faut attendre des
épidémies pour que les autorités pour
que les autorités restent un bol de sang
dans la pièce du coup il va se nourrir
directement il faut que tu le met dans
le micro-ondes par contre tu es con
comme une pendule merci Romain